THAT ROOM TOGETHER,OFFMAN.
BACK TO SHOTS!
REBOUND IN FRONT!
AND A GREAT CHANCE FOR
SENT OUT TO T T IT'S IN!
THEY
FRONT OF HIM AND HERE'S THE
BOUNCING PUCK.
MORE.
UP TO IT AND SCORES!
MASON  THIS ONE IS
COMING A SHOT AND IT'S A KNUCKLE
TO KICK IT OUT AND OFF THE
GRUBAUER AND RIGHT ACROSS TO
CENTRE.
SCORES!  W WHAT'S GOING ON.
GETS IT OUT IN FRONT.
AND PEZZETTA GETS THE RE
WALL.
HE'S GOING TO GET HIS 400thth
PITLICK.
GALLAGHER WITH A CHANCE.
GRUBAUER.
IT.
WILL TAKE OFF WITH IT.  EACH OT?
>> IMAGINE THATAT
McCANN SCORES!
WITH A SNAPSHOT INTO THE TOP RYE
OVER FOR THE WIDE OPEN CAGE AND
DOESN'T GET
OH!
STOPPED BY   EBERLE.
COMES LOOSE.
JOHANSSON ON IT.
LAUZON WITH A SHOT.
KNOCKED DOWN BY MONTEMBEAULT.
[ Cheering ]
ALMOST TWO MINUTES, YOU'RE
EBERLE, FOR THE SUZUKI CAUFIELD
AND PETRY.
FOR
HERE COMES PETRY.
HANDS IT OFF FOR SUZUKI
A LONG   THROUGH
REBOUND IN FRONT OF NET AND THA
CAREER SHOOT-OUT ATTEMPT.
PEZZETTA WITH SPEED, STOPPED BYE
MARCUS JOHANSSON WINS IT FOR